hey Gary I'm a realtor and our team puts
out a lot of video you said it was
important to put out daily content so my
question to you is if you are a realtor
what kind of daily video content would
you produce so that was a tremendous
video that saw all at the vaynernation
pay attention to multiple things
including he was wearing the ROI of your
mother t-shirt the fact he digging the
jab jab jab in the background at random
man walked by in the background which is
reference to some of the stuff we've
done in the show if you're listening on
the podcast I highly recommend you go to
youtube and watch this episode just to
watch this video because it was
tremendous my answer is very simple if I
was a realtor the thing that I would do
more than anything is actually review
the area around the places where I sell
homes let me explain if I'm selling
homes in Millburn New Jersey I'm putting
out a daily piece of content reviewing
this school then I'm interviewing the
individual teachers if I can get access
to them then I'm reviewing every local
business the subway shop the wine shop
then I'm interviewing literally people
that have lived in the neighborhood for
50 years I'm putting out content to make
you romantic around the stories in the
area because people pick them for
utility convenient what I mean by that
is convenience of transportation how
quickly from the office but they also
pick because of the school systems and
there's a lot of data out there on that
but how about making it a little warmer
and interviewing Miss Robinson the third
grade teacher and then obviously kind of
the amenities around it right the
playground you know the best stores I
remember realtor telling me that people
moved to Short Hills because of Wine
Library I thought that was cool
felt like such an anchor to that area
and so what I would do is daily content
on the 20 mile radius or 10 mile radius
around the area where you sell the homes
the stories that are tucked away in the
businesses and the school system and the
iconic neighbors that have been around
forever those stories are the narrative
that will create a motion which will be
on a tipping point scale on a 50/50 may
be the thing that tips someone to buying
your home oh crap wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe